one way in its senior managers don't get
many interviews but today its UK
director broke cover to give Sky News
his response to recent allegations
leveled against the Chinese telecom
equipment giant chief among these is the
accusation that as the UK prepares to
roll out 5g mobile networks while ways a
threat to national security if it helps
we will sign in a non spying agreement
with the UK government there are
mechanisms already in place within the
UK in fact according to n CSC is the
most rigorous activity with with Huawei
globally yet those commitments may not
satisfy everyone the United States Japan
Australia and New Zealand have all
banned Huawei from involvement with the
building of 5g networks in their
countries you think they've caught it
wrong in some respects the United States
is under invested in in 5g if you
contrast that to the UK who put 5g as
central to the industrial strategy so
main concern for huawei's critics is the
company's proximity to the authorities
in Beijing so how close is Huawei to
China's government one waste billionaire
founder ran shank vey is a former
officer in China's armed forces the
People's Liberation Army while he is
also a member of the ruling Communist
Party critics also point to China's
National Intelligence law that says
organizations must support cooperate
with and collaborate in national
intelligence work the US Justice
Department has charged Huawei and its
chief financial officer mr. Ren's
daughter Meng Manzo with fraud and
stealing trade secrets in this country
meanwhile Huawei is waiting for the
government to decide whether or not it's
equipment can be used in the rollout of
5g senior Conservative MPs believe it
should not be we're dealing here with a
company that is in many ways so
integrally part of the Chinese state
that you know the Chinese state doesn't
need to ask what's going through its
networks it has access automatically
after months of criticism both in this
country and abroad Huawei is coming out
fighting however as a trade dispute
relations between the United States and
China it faces an uphill battle as it
protests its citizens here in King sky
news